i
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
que piensan que me imaginé en el
instante que supe que estaba embarazada
por tercera vez
me imaginé las tardes en la plaza con
todos mis hijos los hijos de mis amigas
me imaginé a qué deporte los iba a poder
llevar a todos juntos
pensé en el auto había que salir
enseguida corriendo a cambiar el auto
ahora era huevito sillita mi hija mayor
en el medio como íbamos a viajar como
íbamos a hacer ese primer viaje a la
playa ahora los cinco un lugar que tanto
nos gusta pensé los domingos a la tarde
en la pileta de la casa de mi cuñado y
empecé a imaginar los gritos risas
llantos ahora de tres no dedos
pero con ese embarazo toda esa
estantería de esa maternidad que yo
conocía esa maternidad cierta que me iba
a salir de taquito era el tercero se
vino abajo y no fue no es y no será
nunca lo que yo me imaginé en ese primer
instante
ellos
son mis hijos
ahí están agustín a santiago igual igual
y tiene síndrome de cantú los 8 meses de
embarazo de wally fueron un signo de
pregunta con un futuro totalmente
incierto fueron una constante de agua
lee le pasa algo pero no sabemos qué es
tenemos que estar preparados pero como
te preparas para algo cuando no sabes
que es porque si no sabes no podés hacer
el día que nació wali mi vida esa vida
que yo conocía cambió para siempre pase
a ser esa mamá de la cne o esa mamá del
bebé raro esa mamá a la que todos los
médicos le decían lo siento no sabemos
qué más hacer igual y estuvo internado
sus primeros seis meses de vida y esos
seis meses fueron los más difíciles de
la mía yo me sentí de todas las formas
posibles alegre triste abatida enojada
feliz llena de energía con ganas de
gritar desesperada angustiada lo insulté
adiós
en todos los idiomas
les dije cosas impensadas y terribles a
todos a los médicos los enfermeros a los
amigos a la familia a mi esposo
pero lo que más me marcó fue tener que
dividir me entre ellos 3
porque yo quería estar con wally cuando
estaba con agustina y con santiago
porque no sabía si al día siguiente esta
incubadora iba a estar vacía y quería
estar con aglutina y con santiago cuando
estaba con wally porque los había dejado
en crisis sin entender absolutamente
nada solo necesitando a su mamá porque
cuando pasan estas situaciones se
enferma todo no era solo walt y se
enferma el trabajo la familia el tiempo
la rutina las relaciones se enferma
nuestra capacidad para poder ser
objetivos
y mientras a mí me pasaba todo eso yo me
encontré muchas veces despidiéndome de
igual y sintiendo que necesitaba darle
mi permiso diciéndole hijo yo te
acompaño hasta donde vos quieras llegar
si es hoy está bien si es la semana que
viene también mamita va a estar bien y
me encontré diciéndole adiós barba
escúchame si tienes un plan para él dame
una señal si no por favor llévatelo pero
igual y de alguna manera decidió
quedarse y volvió no una vez sino varias
veces y yo tuve que reaprender a ser
mamá a dejar de lado todo eso que ya
sabía cómo se hacía para hacerlo de
forma diferente tuve que aprender a
bañarlo diferente a darle de comer
diferente a controlar su sueño a manejar
una traqueostomía a saber qué hacer si
eso se complicaba y había que salvarle
la vida y me tocó
yo no puedo describir
es lo que es para una madre tener que
salvarle la vida a un hijo
y tuve que aprender a que las risas y
los llantos de igual sean en silencio
tuve que aprender a entender sus miradas
a prestarle mi voz y tuve que aprender a
esperar yo no sabía por ejemplo si algún
día iba a escuchar que me dijera mamá
así que tuve que aprender a esperar los
tiempos de wally y aún lo sigo haciendo
y también tuve que aprender a convivir
con la mirada del otro esa mirada
incómoda cuando tengo que aspirar lo a
wally por la traqueostomía no importa
donde estoy en el colectivo en el
supermercado en la calle en un
cumpleaños esa mirada incómoda cuando él
hace un berrinche y se me sienta en la
vereda o empieza a gritar en el
colectivo y aprendí que yo adelante
tenía un libro abierto con todas las
páginas
con
y que sí al que la única que podía
escribir esas páginas era yo y que si
dios había decidido regalarme la
posibilidad de ser la mamá de igual y
algún día se iba a encargar de mostrarme
por qué y para qué
una tarde de febrero igual y estaba
internado todavía llega lucy a la
habitación lucía en ese momento era
residente de genética y lucía descubrió
que pasaba con walt y lucía pronunció
por primera vez esas tres palabras
síndrome de canto que es lucía que puedo
ir a comprar a la farmacia nada mamá
porque no sabemos de qué estamos
hablando solo sabemos que hay 50 casos
en el mundo 50 me estás cargando es una
broma bueno no me estaba cargando y esa
era
una enfermedad es rara o poco frecuente
por su incidencia en la población no por
su sintomatología y es así calificada
una époc enfermedad poco frecuente
cuando afecta a 1 de cada 2.000 personas
si uno de cada 2.000 y pensemos en la
población mundial cuántos somos siete
mil quinientos cincuenta millones de
personas en el mundo y hagamos esta
cuenta rápida si un ipad para ser
calificada si tiene que afectar a una de
cada dos mil personas debería haber en
el mundo más o menos tres millones de
personas por el post bueno esto no es
así nosotros éramos sólo 50 y quien se
va a preocupar
y ocupar por 50 así que me iré a lucia
esta basílica con su jefa también en
este momento y les dije y ahora qué
hacemos ahora mamá
ahora ahora escribir la historia de vida
de wallis porque algún día vamos a poder
ayudar a alguien más y ahí también
supimos que la respuesta a lo que pasaba
con wally estaba en san louis missouri
eeuu
ahora yo tenía un título una respuesta a
un punto de partida pero yo necesitaba
desesperadas' desesperadamente saber que
era cantú cómo podía ayudar a wally
necesitaba saber si aglutina y santiago
eran potenciales portadores sí igual y
había heredado de mamá o papá si tenía
que sentarme a hablar con mis hermanas
mis cuñados tengo varios sobrinos algún
día voy a ser abuela pensaba así que
miraba rutina y al santiago y sentía una
opresión en el pecho terrible y miraba
wali conectado un respirador las 24
horas del día en ese momento esa era su
realidad necesitando desesperadamente
que alguien me responda
se pueden morir por tener síndrome de
cantú y ese día yo decidí que no iba a
dejar que quedara nada en el mundo que
yo no intentara para poder ayudar a mis
tres hijos y así tratando de entender
intentando entender intentando aprender
llegué a este centro médico al agua yo
en san luís y me vi envuelto en
conversaciones con ellos reflotando en
inglés oxidado perdiendo el miedo a usar
google sí
me encontré contándoles a los médicos de
rosario todo esto nuevo que yo estaba
descubriendo y me encontré planificando
un viaje en avión a san luís cuando yo
ni siquiera me animaba a salir con walid
a la esquina
san luis es una metrópolis es otro mundo
es una ciudad enorme manzanas repletas
de edificios todos conectados entre sí
donde al principio nosotros nos
perdíamos con frecuencia y nosotros
llegamos al agua hay un miércoles de
madrugada con la valija cargada de
angustia miedo incertidumbre
pero con la necesidad de saber para
poder hacer y con la certeza de que ese
era el único camino que había para walt
y así que lo recorrimos nosotros con él
o esperábamos a que tal vez algún día lo
mejor lo recorra otro allí en el agua
you nosotros nos encontramos con gente
desconocida que nos recibieron con los
brazos abiertos se dedicaron a
enseñarnos que estaban haciendo que
esperaban hacer qué era lo que querían
lograr conocí otras mamás ustedes no
saben lo que es para una mamá poder
mirar a otra los ojos y saber que te
entiende ahí sentís
no felicidad sentís alivio
ese alivio sentís conocí otros chicos
familias enteras y ahí pude empezar a
ver que esa respuesta porque dios había
decidido regalarme la posibilidad de ser
la mamá de walt y empezaba como a cobrar
sentido
vi una luz al final del túnel y supe que
hacía de salud teníamos que ir como
cuando íbamos a llegar yo en ese momento
no tenía ni la más mínima idea
jamás pensé que igual se iba a convertir
en el paciente insignia para el síndrome
de canto en américa latina con
posibilidades de empezar un tratamiento
en un futuro cercano para poder
justamente tratar el síndrome de canto
ni que iba a ser el referente para los
países de habla hispana de repente
empezaron a contactarnos familias de
distintos lugares empecé a trabajar con
estas familias a conectarlas entre sí
ayudarlas muchas de esas se han
incorporado a la investigación como wali
incluso las pude conocer en san luís
como por ejemplo la familia de elizabeth
elizabeth es de chile
elisabeth
nos escribió por primera vez un 14 de
febrero día de los enamorados 11 de la
noche así que imagínense porque me
acuerdo cuando elisabeth nos escribió mi
marido no trabajaba de noche todavía así
que por eso me acuerdo éste elisabeth no
se escribió porque la genetista de ella
le había dicho que su hijo más pequeño
podía tener síndrome de canto y que
hacemos todos cuando nos escribe a
alguien por redes sociales que no
conocemos qué hacemos miramos el perfil
yo veamos las fotos bueno eso hicimos
cuando vimos las fotos de elisabeth y su
familia nos miramos con mi esposo y
dijimos no tiene cantú solamente el n
más pequeño sino todos y así fue como
elizabeth después de 40 años tuvo una
respuesta porque ella se sintió mal toda
su vida y también una respuesta para sus
dos hijos hoy les puedo hablar de nora
norays de honduras pero ella vive en
nashville a 4 horas de san luís la
genetista le dijo nora que había una
familia en argentina que le iba a poder
ayudar frente al diagnóstico de cantú de
su hijita más pequeña
creo que ni si quiera o la d
lo primero que le dije que hace es
hablando conmigo agarra el auto y maneja
esas cuatro horas hasta san luís y tiene
cantú su hija más pequeña y también su
esposo o les puedo hablar de franklin
franklin es de mexico y gracias a dos
estamos logrando que su hija tenga en
breve su examen genético y le estamos
pasando a franklin todo esto que es el
síndrome de cantú acá para que lo pueda
empezar a replicar en mexico y les puedo
hablar de que me encontré tratando de
usar el traductor de google para hablar
con elena de korea es terriblemente
difícil no se habla inglés en muchos
otros países como nosotros pensamos
gracias a dios eso ya está encaminado
con científicos del agua ya historias
como estas tengo muchas en las que igual
y es el puente es el nexo es ese hilo
rojo que une a estas familias con la
esperanza y con la respuesta yo jamás
pensé que iba a estar parada acá
contándoles esta historia maravillosa
jamás pensé que animarnos a subirnos a
un avión iba a cambiar la vida de wally
y la de mucha gente y lo seguirá siendo
todavía
yo jamás pensé que de esos 50 casos
conocidos hoy
seríamos más de 200 lo que hace que yo
me pregunté cuántas historias más habrá
allá afuera cuántos más habrá que no
saben que lo que le está pasando cuántas
elisabeth honor a huelen a habrá allá
afuera jamás pensé que con el aval y el
impuso el impulso y por el pedido del
agua se crearía una fundación busca
fundación síndrome de canto argentina
para trabajar desde ahí por walt y por
todas las personas que tienen y tendrán
síndrome de canto el desafío es enorme
que el camino que hay que recorrer es
muchísimo
igual y tiene para enseñarme cada día
cosas nuevas y me obliga a superarme a
desafiarme a mí misma pero todo valió la
pena vale la pena y valdrá la pena y
todo sólo porque una mamá necesitaba
saber muchas gracias
[Música]